Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on the Supernatural finale the mother of all
cliffhangers went down.
And as crazy as it is to think, Season 10
is going to be one of the most interesting
years they show has ever had.
Metatron even gave one of the best ideas for
a new Supernatural spinoff I’ve heard in
a long time.
If you’re finding me for the first time.
I do all kinds of sci fi and fantasy videos
for shows like Supernatural, Game of Thrones
and Marvel.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And feel free to suggest topics for bonus
videos while Team Winchester is on hiatus.
Time to get Winchestered.
That’s not a sex thing by the way.
I’m going to start with my top 5 moments
and then do my review.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Metatron edges out PewdiePie as
the world biggest Youtube Star
It’s actually a pretty ingenious plan.
If you wanted people to starting thinking
you were god you’d have to use a social
media platform to reach as many eyeballs as
quickly as possible.
And Youtube is the world’s biggest social
media site.
People just forget that because it’s video.
But it’s really a social media tool at it’s
core.
I always thought it was human souls that made
angels more powerful, like when Castiel became
god.
He didn’t literally become god, he just
became so powerful he was LIKE god.
And the same is true of Metatron.
He’s just tapping into the energy of the
Angel Tablet.
That’s why he said that phrase when he was
punching Dean’s lights out.
He was comparing the benefits of being powered
by the word of god, the tablet, versus being
powered by the first blade.
Obviously the word of god is going to be more
powerful, because it’s literally the words
of creation.
I love the idea that he was storing it inside
his typewriter.
I’m guessing he was just translating it
into readable words.
And that was the story he was writing, the
best story ever.
He also spent a lot of time talking to Castiel
this season about how the best artists steal
their material.
Which is funny, because he was essentially
ripping of God, via the tablet.
To write his new story.
He’s still alive, so hopefully in season
10 we’ll learn more about what his story
was going to be.
It’s almost like George RR Martin teasing
out winds of winter on his blog.
Maybe that’s what Metatron will do in season
10.
Number 4 - Castiel Uses Pop Culture To Defeat
Metatron
Getting the villain to monologue while you
secretly broadcast him to the whole school
is an oldie but a goodie.
When Metatron told Castiel he should have
read more he was forgetting that he implanted
the sum total of all pop culture that had
ever existed in his brain.
Remember, Metatron basically copy and pasted
his brain into Castiel.
And Metatron had read every book that had
ever been written, seen every movie that had
ever been made, et cetera.
So in a way, Metatron defeated himself.
I don’t think Castiel would have thought
to do that otherwise.
And now that he’s defeated him, Castiel
is the reluctant leader again.
When Hannah asked him about his Grace I actually
thought he was going to ‘borrow’ Dean
to heal himself like Gadreel did at the beginning
of the Season.
I’ll talk about Castiel Season 10 after
my review.
One of my favorite take aways from this scene
was that Castiel broke the most powerful weapon
in the universe to save one man.
Destiel shippers probably exploded in front
of their tvs.
Number 3 - Crowley Is Getting Restless In
Hell
This all ties into that speech in the diner
where he gets all existential on Dean and
makes him wonder if there’s anything more
for him beyond hunting.
Now that we’ve seen the whole episode, I
kind of think he was foreshadowing Dean becoming
a Demon.
Like Crowley himself was also getting tired
of his daily grind and was just waiting for
Dean to die so the mark would resurrect him
as a demon and they could go on new adventures
together as a pair of demons.
Like Crowley thought he’d replace Sam in
Dean’s life.
As much as Sam made fun of Dean for his bromance
with Crowley, I think Crowley actually really
enjoys having Dean around.
Eternity is boring.
For any Batman fans out there, Ra’s Al Ghul
actually said in the comics once, Memory is
the first casualty of Immortality, I would
say excitement is the second.
Dean turning is like the best thing that could
have happened to Crowley.
It creates is own set of unique problems.
But we can talk about that after my review.
Number 2 - Dean Dies
I always knew one of them would sacrifice
themselves at the end of this season, and
given last year it was Sam’s turn.
It only makes sense that Dean gets his wish
and dies.
Well, not exactly.
We won’t know what his reaction to being
a demon is till episode 1 of season 10.
But up to that point I think Dean was just
happy to be rid of his blade addiction.
He’d really strained his relationship with
Sam, and you guys can let me know what you
thought of the addict storyline, but I think
there’s this idea that you never really
stop being an addict.
Like the drugs never really let you go.
And thus Dean can’t die, not a true death.
and my Number 1 moment - Dean Becomes A Demon
Of all the possible resolutions to the season,
this was one of the best.
I can’t wait to see Dean embrace some of
his more destructive tendencies.
Being that he’s a Demon he’ll still have
his old personality.
Think about Cain, he had the mark and when
we first met him, he seemed pretty normal.
So I’m expecting Dean to still tell the
same jokes and still go for burgers and women.
He’ll just have some Demon urges lumped
on top of all his other vices.
The real question now is how can Sam and Castiel
fix him, or at least bring him into heaven.
Is that even possible?
I think it is, but it’s going to be the
larger Season 10 arc in addition to Castiel
fixing heaven.
That will mean fixing the tablet.
Which only a prophet can do.
I wonder if that means we’ll get to see
Kevin again?
Even though he’s a ghost.
But now it’s your turn, let me know in the
comments what your favorite moment was?
And do you think they’ll be able to save
Dean or will he just live forever as a Demon?
Wouldn’t that be a crazy way for them to
end the series.
With Sam becoming the vessel for an angel
and living forever in heaven and Dean living
forever in Hell as a Demon.
I don’t actually think that’s what’s
going to happen.
Here’s a few of my favorite one liners from
the episode:
The best was Metatron saying winning a People’s
Choice Award.
Not quite the real thing.”
It was a burn against Jensen Ackles and Jared
Paladecki who have won a bunch of People’s
Choice Awards, but never an Emmy.
Although Supernatural as a series has been
nominated for two emmys.
Dean saying, “Hell isn’t complicated.
Game of Thrones and Shower Sex are complicated”
Everyone on staff must really like Game of
Thrones.
I’ve heard more references to it than any
other tv show this season.
Crowley saying, “I guess I’ve been Winchestered”
Metatron saying “They Love me, they really
love me.”
In case you didn’t know Sally Field said
that line after winning back to back Oscars
for movies she had done a long long time ago.
People started making fun of her by putting
it in movies and tv shows.
Jim Carrey said it in The Mask, but you hear
the line all the time all over TV.
Then when Metatron says “Locked Up Abroad
Heaven” Edition.
It’s a reference to the tv series An Idiot
Abroad.
It’s a comedy travel show where Ricky Gervias,
Stephen Merchant and Warwick Davis send a
really dumb person to travel around visiting
places and being silly.
The show is a parody itself.
So Metatron is parodying a parody.
And that is why I love Supernatural.
Overall just comparing this episode to other
Supernatural episodes and finales I’d say
was definitely in my top 3.
I still feel like the season 5 finale was
the best.
Just because that was really meant to end
the series.
They didn’t know they were picked up for
season 6 until after they shot it.
So it was a real deal ending to the show.
You really have to look at Supernatural a
little different than other shows because
it’s been going on for almost 10 years,
which is amazing.
Especially that it’s sustained its popularity.
To that end we really have to get credit to
the characters for being so strong.
This year my favorite was definitely Metatron,
Curtis Armstrong did an interview with Chris
Hardwick at Nerdist where he said he still
can’t get cast in a pilot to save his life.
But I feel like he’s really show how awesome
he can be as the Metatron character.
He really did make for one of my favorite
all time Supernatural villains.
And because the writers used the conceit of
Metatron being a scribe and writing the greatest
story ever written.
It gave them the opportunity to go nuts with
Pop Culture jokes.
Which also became a backdoor to change Castiel
on a fundamental level.
Now Castiel gets all the jokes.
Even though he’s not a tv junkie, his brain
contains all that knowledge now.
I wasn’t as happy with Sam’s arc as I
was with Dean and the Mark of Cain, but he
has all of next year to sacrifice himself
again to save Dean’s soul.
If that’s even possible.
As silly as it is sometimes, I totally think
Supernatural earns all it’s moments.
Like the ridiculousness all comes from a very
logical place inside the universe it’s created
for itself.
So there were never really any plot twists
or character arcs I felt were out of place
or lame.
But here’s where we can talk a little Season
10.
Let’s stick to the big stuff.
Castiel in Heaven and Dean as a Demon.
So Castiel has to finish fixing heaven, because
even though he knows where the entrance is,
there are still a bunch of wayward angels
on earth.
And I think it’s going to involve repairing
the tablet.
They can be repaired, but only by the prophet
meant to read them.
Which means Castiel will probably need Metatron’s
help.
Who is currently rotting in Heaven’s prison.
Then there’s Dean and Crowley.
Dean is a demon now, he still has the mark
of cain and the first blade.
So he’ll have a little more power over his
urges to kill.
But he’ll still be a threat to Crowley.
I like the idea that Dean might make a play
for the Throne of Hell by using the first
blade on Crowley.
But I don’t see the series ending with Dean
becoming the King of Hell.
That’s just a nice fantasy that I’ll let
tumblr explore.
What I do expect is that the Brothers will
be reunited in an unusual way.
Like they’ll end up together.
But I expect there to be some weird twist.
I fully expect Castiel to survive all of this
intact too.
His Grace will be restored.
I don’t want to make too many predictions
before they start teasing us with actual details
for season 10 episodes.
But I’ll bet they drop some bombs at Comic
Con this summer.
So i’ll be sure to do another video when
we get more info.
In related news, if there’s any special
supernatural bonus videos you want me to do
this summer, just let me know in the comments
and I’ll add them to my list.
Tuesdays are typically going to be Marvel/Star
Wars days though.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here for all my Supernatural
videos and click here for the new Guardians
of The Galaxy Trailer.
High fives everybody, You’ve just been winchestered.
See you tomorrow!